[Music]
hey what's up guys welcome to winners on
a Wednesday this week I have the
pleasure of bringing onto the show
gareth van Rensburg how's it going buddy
very good Samuel thanks for having me
you know what I'm really really grateful
that you've been on the show you've had
some cracking deals since doing some
training why don't you just give us a
little bit of background a little bit
about yourself and we'll walk kickoff
brilliance well I came over to England
in 1999 on a journey basically just a
six-week holiday but I stayed and I
thought myself well this is a lovely
country so I'm gonna stay here well I
almost did the same when I went to South
Africa yeah I'm fantastic
so basically didn't mark my wife come
over to join me on this and we decided
to buy a first house in 2001 to get the
clue story on own little family and
since then we've been interested in
property but our careers took off so we
needed to go and work and do our own
things but in 2009 when the crash
happened
in 2008-2009 basically my husband's
house it was rented out and I saw I was
getting more renting than what I did
before and that triggered something in
my mind that maybe you should look
further into this because there's
something that's actually happening
there
Wow so we sat down as a family and we
discussed well you know we couldn't sell
this house in 2000 when we actually
moved in 2002 is there anything that we
can do to actually invest further in
property because this one's renting out
now and it's been renting out for two
years at a really good rental income um
the more each was completely lower so we
were making a really good profit so we
decided desig we're gonna look at other
ways to actually do it so were you like
an accidental landlords but I was next
it I wasn't expecting to be a landlord
what actually happened was we moved into
this house a two bit house and we stayed
for 18 months and we had children so we
decided to move to a three bed and we
tried to sell it but at the time the
market was completely dead yeah we
couldn't send it so you moved out and
rented so you became a tenant again yeah
which is really good because I think
it's Grant Cardone who says that you're
better off to be a tenant yourself and
then buy somewhere and rent out so you
kind of did that accidentally and
realized how much money you'll make
again exactly that's not and then what
happen so didn't basically laughs took
over we had to shoot their children and
we saw bring them up and then in 2014 a
career change where I decided okay
I was made redundant basically so I
decided to look at new adventures so I
started my own little business at first
to see if I could make money and that
started going well what was that
business enjoy hosting so we actually
host people's websites for them cool and
then in 2015 I was watching YouTube one
day and your name pops up and I thought
to myself okay yeah HMOs do they really
really work and that's got me interested
and I thought I'm gonna come to your
crash course just to see exactly what
it's actually about so you hang on a
minute though because 2015 that was what
four years ago now sorry yes so so you
it took you a long time crash course
what took me so long
no cut so blooper again yeah but and
basically then we started looking up at
that time we were actually looking at
property but we couldn't afford to buy
in our local area because prices and
extra skyrocketed yeah so was like 2017
it was you you're on YouTube
yeah I don't know cuz I've been on
YouTube since 2015 maybe it took you a
few years I climbed the exact dates but
I found you where you're actually on
YouTube talking about HMOs yeah and how
you could take a two or three bit house
and turn into a five bit yeah quite
easily yeah and make mess of returns so
I decided to cut them come and meet you
yeah and I went to the crash course and
I brought my father my mother and my
wife as well - they said crash course
and was absolutely amazing
yeah we walked away with that absolutely
opinions with new ideas and new ways of
doing things
so what we did was we invested up north
yeah in single it's because that's the
way that we like doing it and we bought
a nice one off your list as well or
Freudian yarning lists and we bought
there for forty thousand pounds and we
get four hundred and fifty pounds a
month waiting for this so you bought it
for forty thousand and you're renting it
for four fifth day yeah that is an
incredible yield yeah and I bet the
return on investment is even better
did you get a mortgage on that property
yes the mortgage is 146 pounds a month
so the mortgage is that interest only or
repayments repayments repayment so
you're paying 146 pound a month and
that's that's that's gonna that's
repayment so the interest is the
interest payments must be probably half
that already imagine yeah so it's
basically in my mind the way I like to
do things is I go into an area yeah
where I don't just blindly walking to an
area yeah I first go into the area and
the entire area to see what
manufacturing is happening there to see
if there's any people building houses
and I found that the area that I chose
to focusing there was actually
manufacturing being built so people were
building factories for people to working
so that's how I choose my areas as well
yeah that's great yes so the house that
we that was rented out and sweet
absolutely fine since then and I think
the cool thing is about that is not only
is it giving you a really good return on
investment what kind of returns are you
getting over 20% yeah because I know you
like me you won't touch if it's less
than 20% it's gotta give me a good
return we fire up any involved in this
yeah yeah but but also not only that but
these properties you bought them really
cheap you're renting them out very well
but the capital appreciation is expected
to be really good as well because these
properties are bottled out haven't they
so we've got hopefully what are you what
are your expectations for the future of
the price of the property well basically
I'm expecting their price to go up to
70,000 in the next five to six years
yeah so at the moment we you know
contraction environment so once the
expansion happens after bricks it's
finished and everything else I'm
expecting those prices to go up to
around about 65 to 70 thousand pounds
yeah for that same property and well at
the end of the mortgage you'll have
you'll have paid it off yeah so that
basically it's almost like the tenants
the tenants rent you're getting a few in
Japan another profit well the way that
we work at is we work very differently
to most people way we've got a separate
accounts where all those links going to
yeah and we actually accumulate it so
you actually buy more
so we brilliant so we don't actually
spin it we don't use that money at all
yeah so on your crash course we learned
how to actually create different
accounts and put the money into
different accounts yeah
so we following the exact same strategy
order on all the houses and that makes
complete sense because I can see in that
pocket we got money for maintenance in
that pocket week we've got money for
buying new ones and that's for spending
or other things as well so fantastic
works I love that and ultimately then
like you buy one house for 40 grand that
deposit how much deposit did you put
down and we put out 25 percents so it's
only ten thousand pounds yeah so ten
grand
legal fees yeah doesn't yeah so all in
all where you probably it's less than
comfortably less than fifteen yeah so
people think I can't afford to buy a
house is
pensive actually you don't need that
much money and then once you've done
that if you set it up right and put the
profits into a separate bank you can
then start slowly snowballing it and it
just gets bigger and bigger here and
you've also I know you've been working
on some Lease Option agreements and some
other types of deals yes which is which
is fantastic what have you learned from
the training then so what's been the big
up the main thing I took away from the
training was mind sets you've got to
change your mind sees in the way you
think yeah stop thinking about should I
do it or how am I gonna do it gets
trained up and you know exactly how to
it follow a process on exactly what you
do it every day and then just do that
yeah stop overthinking things yeah I
know we were talking about earlier about
them to have time for training gears but
then also hand put on implementation as
yeah because you can if you go on a
training course but you don't do it then
it's actually completely pointless yeah
so after did actual DfE I went away and
I'll be nice my big day flipped like two
weeks afterwards yeah and my stuff my
wife brings up to Leeds area and we
looked at over 35 properties and then we
went to Durham and we looked at further
fully properties so geez and you've been
find such good deals I mean they're
ridiculous like that first one that you
bought was what like 20% below market
value wasn't yeah so what was the what
was the true value of that one you
bought it for 40 what was it worth was
worth sixty five thousand sixty five
thousand yeah I've seen the figures how
how can you be sure that it really is
worth sixty five thousand well we're
going to right move and we actually look
at the actual previous properties sold s
so you actually get a good feeling of
what they actually sold it so you can
see what the actual value was at that
time yep so that's how we actually do
our our basis and also by speaking to
estate agents and getting their
indication as well yeah how much sex you
sell for yeah total state agents look at
the street see what that one sold for
others like it fantastic well that's
great and your second property as well
that was also heavily below market now
yeah
yes we actually got that for fifty eight
thousand and they wanted 70 for that
initially the was 70 for it you got it
for 58 yeah
how much was it worth when you bought it
probably sixty five thousand yeah
sixty-five again quite heavily below
market value how much you renting that
one out for awful for fifty a month as
well for fifth day and let me ask you a
question because one of the things that
people I think are scared of and it'd be
great to get your view on
because you've been there and done it
now over the last till six twelve months
is they're worried that they're gonna
buy one of these cheap houses up north
they're gonna buy really cheap they're
gonna rent it out the return on
investment on paper looks fantastic but
their concern is that they're gonna
because it's such a cheap house they're
going to attract really bad tenants they
never have problems nightmares bad
management it's just gonna be a headache
how have you found your experience over
the last well how long have you owned
these for them
well I've owned the first one for 18
months and the second one for six months
now
okay so what's your experience been on
that what's the what's it like I had a
bad tenant as my first tenants and it
was debts it was a complete catastrophe
they destroyed the house how they
destroyed the house completely inside so
okay we'll get back to that in a minute
but okay carry on
yeah so after that I learned from the
processes of basically stop trying to
take anybody and who comes along yeah
and stick to a strict criteria off a
person that you want to arrange your
house yes so I decided to go for
families who needed to go to local
schools so that's the way I did yeah
really interesting rip massive lesson
then yeah it was we couldn't believe us
when we got a phone call one Monday
morning to say that there stopped paying
rains and that they basically destroyed
the whole house inside how much did it
cost to get it all fixed up five and a
half thousand yeah five and a half
thousand Wow we couldn't believe it it
was very expensive mistake yeah that was
and and that's something that was before
you went to the DfE though I wasn't it
yeah yeah yeah it was because I know
what the DfE we we talked about we
talked about this kind of thing so Wow
okay so what did you learn from that
then you learn to vet the tenants
properly I actually learned the first
thing was use the correct agents yeah
vet the agents to make sure that they
know what they're talking about
important thing yeah yeah then get them
to vitiate the actual tenants and do
credit checks and do everything else as
well because yeah vitally important
because if you because if it's cost
involved are thousand-pound that that's
a lot of nice that's like it's a profit
gone for the year yeah yeah and it's
like 10% of the value of the house it's
absolute madness you must have felt
absolutely heartbroken when that
happened I couldn't understand why
somebody would actually do this because
my mind what I'm trying to do is create
a lovely home for families to living
yeah what they can live in a bring up
their children
yeah and just enjoy life do you think
that so in one way that's the kind of
story why people are scared what do you
think is gonna make sure that doesn't
happen again or could it happen again
I'm not saying it's not going to happen
again it could happen again but now
we're extra vigilant on who comes into
our houses
yeah we've also gone one step further
and we'll it proofed the house so we've
putting new carpets that's oh actually
they actually plastic-based
so they can't be destroyed no matter
what yes they look really nice they feel
really nice but you can mesh bleach or
oil on them it's not going to destroy
them they are completely bulletproof
great tip yeah I don't know me that I do
is I put decent carpets in but all of
the two different colors so brown and
then like a beige you know I'm talking
about yeah and they're quite harder but
they look nice they feel nice but if you
spill things on them it doesn't show up
very easily which is much better than
like cream carpet in a tented house yeah
so these little tricks and tips are
really important on those being an
investor and I also stopped providing
white goods because we found that they
were breaking down quite often because
people weren't looking after them yeah
so we stopped providing white goods and
we just painted house make it look nice
yeah and rinse it out do you think that
is a problem just generally speaking as
being a landlord full stop or do you
think that it's because the houses of
the Ybor were so cheap 40 50 grand type
houses is is do you think that is gonna
attract bad people do you regret buying
those houses or do you think that no I
don't I don't regret buying it all
because I've seen cases where even in
expensive houses the same thing happens
mmm
so it hasn't stopped me from changing
strategy I'm still continuing the same
strategy as I have before yeah I'm still
and I wouldn't consider them cheap
houses it's just how this way people
can't afford to buy them basically so we
actually happen that at the local woman
yeah yeah and I mean away yeah do it all
I've kind of notes because I've got a
lot of houses that are similar to yours
I've got properties in Middlesbrough and
places where I bought them for say 56
grand rent them out for about 500 pounds
a month fraternal investment is
fantastic
there are some areas that are benefit
streets
shall we say or
very undesirable areas red-light
districts broken glass in the street you
can just tell I don't want to buy a
house here but just because an area is
very cheap and the houses are 5060
thousand pounds it doesn't necessarily
mean that the people are bad because at
the end of the day people are people and
there's often really large communities
and and villages and the states where
the people are very nice and and the
families are great but it's just a very
cheap area and you're gonna get a much
higher return on investment so why what
are the pros and what do you think are
the cons if there are na about buying
properties that are really really cheap
and what what are the when I say cheap I
mean low value what would you say the
pros and cons are the actual pros are
you can buy lots of them because you
don't need a lot of capital outlay you
have to buy them the cons are they're
quite far north so you need a good power
team to be able to stand by you and make
sure that those properties on the softer
all the time yeah because basically
where I live to the properties is more
than a seven-hour journey it's too far
for me to to actually travel so what
I've done is I've built a power team
around me that looks off to every aspect
of the property so I only have to make
one phone call and that team sorts
everything up for me yeah hunter and
that's one of the things I know we do
that are the deal fawning extravaganza
and we talk about your patch and your
power team talk to us a little bit about
that and how that helped with what
you've done
well basically from where I was before
I'd have to organize by the carpets
organize the court copies to be sent to
the house yeah we're now the the owner
of the company
I tell him which carpet I want he buys
them and he's at the house when they
delivered so he takes care of the
delivery he takes care of the
maintenance work he goes in once a month
to inspect the house for me as well yeah
so if the bottom he's fixing he can spot
problems before they actually happen
yeah which is essential when we close
the thing is if you just move tenants in
who are unreferenced and you you move
them in because you're desperate to just
get a quick turn and then you don't have
anybody going and checking up on the
property you don't have a good
management company you don't have them
credit checked you're asking for
problems really aren't ya that's just oh
no you don't know what's going to happen
something is going to happen yeah so
what are the lessons then what the Pratt
lessons of making sure that you don't
have big problems with these because you
can't argue the return on investment the
return on investment is it's very very
high the problem is if then you have a
turn trash the place or lots of void
periods what would you say that
practical evidence to eliminate that
risk are I would say for me it's you
find out find the actual right length
and so fund their rights
estate agents yeah okay key I've used
some in the past that couldn't rent the
house out and they told me that my price
range is too high yeah when I change
estate agents they said to me no it's
not the price of the rent is just debts
they were pocketing marketing the
property correctly so once I changed the
correct estate agents think she's got
much better also mindsets you can't
worry about real property all the time
it doesn't do you any justice it just
makes you ill yeah so you got to have a
very positive outlook and just think
your puppies are gonna be fine because
you've got a good team that's they're
looking off to it for you yeah because I
suppose a lot of people ask me Gareth
how do you buy properties up north if
you can't go and expect him every day
I'm going well I don't need to I employ
other people to do it for me they look
after the property I don't have to worry
about it I don't worry about it because
with every property I basically
purchased I was to make sure that
there's a year's money in the bank for
any voids yeah so to make if it isn't
rented out for six months or seven
months I'm not worried about it because
it's money in the bank they can look
after that one property yeah so that's
very important that's brill really
really key lessons they're really key
lessons talk to me about how you've
managed to save the deposits and stuff
as well because i know that's been
something you've done really well now
you're moving on to doing things like
lease option agreement sourcing
properties and different stuff which is
kind of the cheating way but you've up
until now you you've worked really hard
to say the deposit start tell me a bit
about i've done that well basically we
invest in training your training and a
financial training as well and one of
the key aspects they was break down your
finances so you know exactly what's
going on so we decided to get rid of all
luxuries as you can say like Sky TV and
everything else so we created four
accounts the one is emergency funding
where we put money into every month
for emergencies yeah the second is the
fun accounts they were useful spending
just for two going out going out for
meals and weaves and things the third
one is expenses of things that we need
to fix around the house for maintenance
and things like that yeah this is our
private one and then the third one is
basically a savings account just for
investments yeah so we put money in
there every month we don't move money by
ourselves it's done automatically so we
haven't got a we don't get involved in
that process yeah for the bank accounts
for the property we've got exactly the
same thing set up where when people pay
their rent we take 45% footed mortgages
and keep that in one account and then
the risk is broken up into maintenance
savings and more investments basically
yeah we can buy more properties and that
way you can see exactly what's coming in
what's going out yeah you can work out
because sometimes people don't even know
what their properties are giving them as
a return because they don't the money's
coming here chromic go in there and
they've got no idea so that's really
good that you're doing that and and and
what we've all been said now you've now
you've got the properties up and running
you've got them tenant it with you bore
the budgets in place what kind of return
on investment are you chief property is
giving you the first ones given me over
20% in the second one I would say is 19%
the property down south it's probably in
a region of seventeen and a half percent
very good yeah very good love that so
what your plans for the future that the
plan for this series because we set
goals every year yeah to get more vital
rates this year for more yeah and then
in the future getting involved in bull -
rents because I can see there's a big
place in the market for bull to rents in
this country as well yeah fantastic
what have been the real key learning
points through not only the training but
also actually doing the dough and going
out there and viewing so many houses
what have been the real key learning
points as an investor for me it was
basically learning everything about your
patch learning exactly what's happening
in the area that the data that you're
getting investing yeah because we went
to look at areas where we weren't
completely comfortable with the area
yeah but once we knew exactly that
there's actually industry
funding coming to that area they would
actually do that and it's just knowing
your numbers we have Excel spreadsheets
so when we actually make offers on
properties we go according to the
external spreadsheet and we don't go
anything over the HR screeches yeah
fantastic
love that and how have you changed
because I know won't weren't you know
you're we've become friends now and
you're invested really really well
you've been very very hands-on you've
implemented a lot of what we've learned
as a person how would you say you've
changed over the last week since you
started investing there the last year
enough as a person I've changed my whole
mindset I'll stop worrying I've stopped
my anxiety about everything basically
turned my mind into a mini computer if I
can put it like that yeah
for me property's a numbers game every
day I get up and I think okay I've got
to make 50 phone calls today yeah to
find deals and I won't stop until make
50 phone calls yeah and that's it so
I've become much more productive in
everything I do because I applied that
same format to every other area of my
life so instead of thinking about how am
I gonna do that or should I do that
there's no thoughts this is what I have
to do today and I'll do that first yeah
to make sure it's done only then do I do
other things love that and you've been
really resilient you know you we spoke
earlier about not giving up there are
setbacks sometimes in properties
sometimes disappointments I know you've
had some really juicy deals that have
fallen through literally sometimes the
day before right tell us about that one
well a good example is we were
negotiating a leasehold would with it
with a person that was looking to sell
his house so we decided get we'd offer
him a figure based on a five year option
yeah where we'd buy his house after five
years and he was really interested and
this was in stockton-on-tees
so he was really interested and then the
day before we were going to sign the
contract he's brother said to him no I
think she'd rather sell this house so it
fell down right at at that's at that
point but you lose so many winsome yes
absolutely and you need to just
celebrate your success discipline your
disappointment and just and just keep
moving and another example is below
market values um I went to the pier
property in Durham and it was selling at
65,000 for to bed the estate agent said
to me would you would you make an offer
on this I said I wouldn't give off a
more than 40
thousand fruits and she was like no
don't no one take this yeah and she
throw me back to the following Monday
said would you like to revise her offer
I said no I'm only gonna go up as high
as 40,000 I'm not going to pay any more
and she said sorry the owners not going
to take that and then two months later I
got a phone call from a citation going
they'll take it off the Garreth there we
go there you go so it's just don't give
up yeah keep on going and you never know
when when the fruit of your labor is
going to come out do you you can put a
lot of work and you think I've been a
really unproductive week but then if
you've put the work in sometimes two
months later you might get a phone back
like that yeah so no that's that's
that's incredible and I think as well I
know I know you're a very detailed
person in a way you take action but you
your numbers your numbers driven and we
were talking earlier a little about
there's a lot of motivated idiots out
there and you know property can be if
you know what you're doing and you and
you're trying to package deals and so
you're a compliant property sorcerer
I am so you've set it properly so you
you can you can pass deals on and make
money that way
you've bought single out properties
you've got lease option agreement now
that you've learned and mastered it and
you're ready and you're ready to find
some and do some but how important do
you think it is to get the right
training before you go and start trying
to make money in this industry it's
vitally important if you haven't had
proper training you just going in
circles basically if you get proper
training you've got a clear path you
know exactly what you need to do yeah
and you can do it but for instance the
5,000 pounds that you spent on that
trashed property that probably wouldn't
have happened if you'd have had the
right training and known how to vet
tenants and stuff it's all hands so it's
water under the bridge now but with the
right training that could have
potentially been being eliminated but uh
that's great have you made a lot of
friends in doing the training as well
have you got do you feel like you've got
people around you now a fantastic
community on Facebook and also offline
as well
yeah it's nice being around like-minded
people who doing the same thing as you
yeah because you get really good ideas
and you learn more about the Xbox game
then you would be doing it by yourself
yeah I think as well a lot of the
training is free you know you can about
being a landlord there's forums out
there there's you know there's articles
there's podcasts where you
can learn about being a landlord
managing tenants getting your power team
together the training that I do is very
much about how to find deals and how to
make money but the everyday management
side of it I think a lot of it is just
putting yourself giving it giving you
putting the time aside to really just
study up and learn that's more important
what advice would you give to someone
that was just sort of starting out and
was wondering where to invest that money
what would you what would you say to
them I'd say come to the crash course to
understand what property is all about
yeah and meet people who are on the same
journey as you yeah it's absolutely
important well yeah I mean the property
investors crash courses yeah is an Oprah
and it's free yeah so it's it is a no
brainer well I've been really pleased to
see you do well the deals that you've
done have been have been incredible
thanks so much for coming on the show
and look forward to seeing you smash out
of the park another year thank you sir
thank you guys god bless you too yes my
name is Samuel Leeds thank you for
watching winners on a Wednesday every
single week we interview a success
students for your inspiration you can
watch more right here on the playlist as
a whole playlist of them so what you'll
notice is every single winner on a
Wednesday always starts with them coming
to my two day crash course so if you
would like to be a winner on a Wednesday
literally come on my crash course and
who knows in three months time you could
be here in my offices on this show as a
winner on a Wednesday so get yourself
booked on the crash course watch more
have fun I'll see you next week